smith there's been a lot flying around
on the internet in regards to
you know that slap that you gave to the
unformidable
chris rock
you know physically unformidable person
yeah
i'm sure you regret it you've already
apologized i'm not speaking about the
morality or immorality of that i want to
dig deeper into something which i feel
is at the crux of the issue
which i think
may be okay and i'm not trying to
diagnose you particularly but i'm just
putting out there
a an issue of cognitive dissonance that
you actually have now cognitive
dissonance for those who don't know
is when you have
uh you know conflicting attitudes or
beliefs about something right which
causes you uncomfort from a
psychological perspective now what
exactly am i talking about look think
about it right you probably are a
consumer of feminist ideology and the
reason why i say that is because you're
an open relationship with a woman
who's spoken who's jada you know who's
spoken openly and candidly about
polyamory and uh you know all these kind
of things so obviously that discourse is
antithetical to say a nuclear family you
know setting or arrangement
where you have a typical let's say
traditional roles of males and females
the man is the breadwinner the woman is
the you know
wherever she is and or she may have more
than one role
but that there is some kind of a
managerial hierarchy within the
household where the man
is at the top of the hierarchy
you see in the traditional roles you
have a managerial hierarchy and the man
has responsibilities say the
responsibilities of protection
of breadwinning and so on
in exchange the man has rights
okay as well for that breadwinning and
for that protection
which are for example that the man is to
be respected as the let's say
commander-in-chief the final
decision-maker in certain things
and uh that of course there's
exclusivity on behalf of the woman okay
in the relationship
uh and in some cultures including the
islamic culture which i come from
polygyny is allowed proligenie meaning
that a man can marry multiple women but
a woman that she cannot do that
so this is the kind of dynamic we're
talking about when we talk about
traditional
family roles obviously traditionalism is
different depending on where you go or
what you do however what i want to say
to you is think about this for a second
will smith yeah
you
got up
and slapped a man okay now i'm not
talking about once again the morality of
it
that the point that you felt the need to
protect
jada your partner
why do you feel a need to protect her
this is my question because if you
consume a second wave feministic
discourse then it's not about protecting
the woman
because really protection should be
split 50 50 a woman should be able to
protect herself in fact she should be
outrightly
well sorry downrightly right
um
appalled at the fact that you
by standing up doing what you did
that she feels the need to be protected
because as a feminist as a person who
believes in equal rights that she should
get up herself why did she even look at
you i mean this famously she looked at
you in a certain way and you felt an
expectation but here therein lies the
issue because they're in shows the
inconsistency in a way
you need to feel
like you need to uphold traditional
roles
the like of which i've already
elaborated upon which can take more than
one form and permutation but at the same
time we feel the need
to acquiesce and capitulate to a
feministic discourse which indicates
equality in all cases
but it's like in this case you are
conflicted between two different
paradigms the tradition is paradigm
which says that the man is the protector
and that he ought to protect the woman
and so on and the feministic paradigm
which doesn't have any of that and we're
seeing the collapse as a tangent here
and i'll come back to the point of the
feministic paradigm when it comes to the
ukraine issue right now which i haven't
spoken about because i'm not an expert
on it
you'll realize i haven't released any
videos because
you know i don't want to have a
half-baked analysis on anything right
but the point is with one thing about
the ukraine issue is that men are being
forced to fight for their country and
women and children can leave
but where are the feminists to say in
fact this shouldn't be the case because
there should be equality yeah with men
and women in this case in terms of
military putting your life on that
literally putting your life on the line
um so we're seeing an inequality there
right
or an inconsistency then feministic
discourse
it shows the entitlement that feministic
discourse actually brings to the table
it's not about actual equality that they
want to see manifest in the political
social and economic sphere as they claim
it's in fact a matter of getting as much
as you can
through entitlement as possible and this
is what i think is happening in your
relationship by the way yeah
so you are conflicted between the
traditionalist protective role get my
wife's name out of your effing mouth why
do you feel the need to say that very
loudly why do you why because you feel
like you need to protect her but once
again
the protective aspect of a relationship
yeah is not required in a feministic
relationship yeah if you're walking in a
street and someone tries to fight jada
she should fight she should defend
herself
she should defend herself this should be
what it is i want to give you another
thought experiment now assume it wasn't
chris rock that was speaking on the you
know that you slapped or you
you hurt him yeah
assume it was a woman that you slept
assume it was a woman comedian yeah like
she was on there and she was getting and
you slapped her
i believe
that the social reaction of these
feminist lefty people that i've seen a
lot of their kind of articles to see the
social reactions yeah
would have been completely different
like
the fact
that many feminists have not considered
this yeah or lefties or whatever people
on the left in american
politics that have put on these opinion
we've seen these kind of like you know
new york times opinion uh articles and
so on we've seen these kind of things
yeah where it's not being condemned
in the way that it should be but the
question is why well sometimes even
apologetic way that way a person
shouldn't i've read one time a person
shouldn't accept a joke or something
like that someone was writing this in in
a newspaper
the reason why is because
deep down even feminists realize
as with the ukraine issue as with the
will smith issue
they realize there is a disparity here
in in the way men are being dealt with
versus women are being dealt with but
once again if that disparity exists why
not cater for it in social and political
life so going back to the point will
smith look
your problem is less
about jada smith
it's not you cannot
that's hopefully that's her name yeah
it's not about that woman
it's
more to do with you bro
can you do you know do you know why
because you haven't chosen a path for
yourself
you haven't chosen a path for yourself
in relation to morality in relation to
ideology in relation to what is the
purpose of life these questions have
have not been answered by you i'm not
going to give you the answer to these
questions right now it's not the time
and place for it but what i'm going to
say to you bro is that once you remove
that cognitive dissonance which you may
have i'm not diagnosing you yeah but you
may have i'm just putting it out there
and you start thinking about you know
what if this if these are the principles
familial and domestic and so on
principles that i put and live my life
with then i'm gonna i'm gonna follow it
through to its logical conclusion
because why should you yeah
have to offer an additional protective
role to a woman who doesn't believe that
it's in her
it's her right to have it
in fact maybe insulting on her paradigm
for you to offer such a role why should
you do that
it makes no sense
and with that concluded
goodbye